aujourd'hui nous sommes le 9 janvier les
chiens et les téléspectateurs le savent
j'espère que vous aussi aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est c'est quoi
mathieu la grève c'est l'anniversaire
d'une personne qui m'est très cher
esther ta maman ou belle maman tu te
fous de la confiture dans la gueule et
ses amis et s il te plait toi tu reviens
gentiment dans l'émission calme toi et
arrête de faire ce geste on dirait qu'il
va nous bénir à chaque fois c'est bon
l'abbé le cas voilà tu commences à
refaire si radio toi le cul c'était
l'anniversaire de lara fabian
aujourd'hui merci me marie kumar avait
un sens bah voilà aujourd'hui c'est à
dire ça mais rappelons que j'adore mais
sa voix des comprimés de nous cassent
pas l'ambiance quand on entend on
t'appellera les chéris juste est ce que
vous avez pensé à ma mère est ce que
vous avez un cadeau pour elle
castaldi est ce que j ai pensé alors non
au nord de bogota pas de cadeau j'ai pas
de cadeau beinheim c'est lui envoyer un
petit mot non non non menteuse
non jean-michel j'y pensais depuis
plusieurs jours ouais évidemment j'ai
quelque chose
non non à ce qu'elles étaient jeu est
très bien
non
vous
[Applaudissements]
savez vous savez à quoi on assiste que
là ça va quoi on assiste ça c'est comme
les mauvais élèves voilà quand il voit
les bons élèves ébahis leur tombe dessus
ce rallye c'est pas parce que tu es la
dernière de la classe il faut cracher
sur le premier les bonnes questions mais
n'est pas parce que ma mère tu le tiens
continue elle va plus regarder c'est que
de la télé n'en passe alors qu'elle
regarde tous les jours c'est vrai bah
oui elle adore les programmes courts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est pour ester parce que je la
trouve très belle
elle respire la montée puis grâce à elle
on a un génie parmi eux 70 à dos un
bouquet de fleurs cadre qui est un cadre
i oui par mathieu qu'est ce que tu as
mon chéri un très beau cadeau pour le
noir et famille s'agrandit taqwa
oublions delormeau prison qu'est match
mathieu hanouna puisque
[Applaudissements]
pour les messieurs elle en veut pas
damart montiel qu'on a eu un an du v
mais vous que j'avais pas traîner votre
maman comme elle l'avait rencontré ma
mère
oui et ma mère il est au téléphone ma
mère denis oui je vous aime beaucoup
tout ça vous laissez pas le voulais vous
parler mais je suis témoin joint au
téléphone et ma mère lui a dit vous
verrez vous saurez bientôt qui je suis
oui alors c est ce que tu peux sortir
les caméras si le plan ne me vois pas il
est professionnel et oui mais oui les
devants aux bouchons je voulais dire à
votre mère que ça très heureux de
l'inviter à déjeuner comme je l'avais
promis nord ou non c'est ce que je veux
faire pour voilà voilà demander quel
cadeau apprécié parce qu'elle va pas
voir tous les cadeaux non plus c'est un
cadeau de déjeuner c'est vrai que c'est
pas un cadeau de ouf c'est la photo que
l'appel et je vais voir quel cadeau elle
préfère tiens d'ailleurs sur twitter
quelques cadeaux préférés ou en mer le
cadre les fleurs ou le déjeuner et
bernard montiel
on va lui demander à m il faut dire
qu'un attendu c'est dans le cadre des
échanges nous disputent les faveurs
oui mais ça va on à l'antenne nature
épouse ont fait quoi 18h42 je vais des
fougasses dis moi non j'ai trois cadeaux
à proposer alors à quand je t'explique
parce que c'est ton anniversaire déjà de
bonnes anniversaire mais c'est une bonne
anniversaire 10 mois alors qu'elle croît
pas l'antenne mais tu sais bien tu finis
l'antenne à 4 heures du matin
la 4l bon alors je t'ai suite les quatre
ans là on en voit souvent tout en vrac
est tous d'accord bosses aux jeux de
turin je te réveilles daou quoi sans qui
la dérange je te réveilles pourquoi là
tu faisais quoi mais non j'étais encore
apte et aidera cuisine d'accord donc
c'est une écoute que d'une oreille mais
je te regarde tous les jours ah ben
ouais vous rendez compte on va chasser
des tas d'or les programmes courts ce
niveau là bas alors il y avait il y
avait 3 il y avait trois cadeaux il ya
wabo qui est là où un bouquet de fleurs
de jean michel maire ou le cadre ouah
cadres avaient bon moral est bon alors
c'est le bouquet ou bien mathieu
delormeau kit offre un cadre dégueulasse
non ou bien bernard montiel qui t'invite
à déjeuner
[Applaudissements]
j'ai compris tu choisis le bouquet de
jean-michel voilà jean michel bavoil
avril t'embrasse très fort encore brad
may bon anniversaire
merci d'embrun merci je t'embrasse à
l'univers
[Applaudissements]